Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant Reactionary
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
globally debased and humiliated herself yesterday
during a hearing.
This is a hearing during which she attacked
the witness, Alejandro Mayorkas, and also
accused fellow member of the House, Eric Swalwell,
of, I guess, sleeping with a Chinese spy was
the language that she used.
We're going to look at that in a moment.
This was so against not only common sense
and decorum, but also the rules of these hearings
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE was banned from
speaking for the rest of the hearing after
this completely unhinged rant.
Here, she calls Mayorkas a liar.
Her words are taken down.
And then it is noted that she is no longer
allowed to speak.
No longer allowed to speak.
Speaker 3: Outrage, complete outrage where
China is poisoning America's children, poisoning
our teenagers, poisoning our young people.
How long are you going to let this go on?
Speaker 4: Congresswoman, let me assure you
that we're not letting it go on.
We are fighting this.
Speaker 3: No, I reclaim my time.
You're a liar.
You are letting this go on in the numbers.
Well, no.
Speaker 4: Actually, I want you to take the
words of the speaker down.
So in making a ruling on this, it's pretty
clear that the rules state you can't impugn
someone's character.
Identifying or calling someone a liar is unacceptable
in this committee.
And I make the ruling that we strike those
words.
Sorry.
Just a point of order.
Legitimate question.
You're recognized.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
Did you move to take the words down or to
strike them?
Mr. Thompson.
Sorry, I just stepped in to take them down.
So what we do?
Yeah.
I'm saying.
My understanding is that words are taken down.
That means that the the member can no longer
speak in whatever the proceeding is.
Oh, boy.
Those words were said.
I.
Speaker 1: That's Congressman Goldman there.
Speaker 3: Personal inquiry.
Point of personal inquiry.
Speaker 4: There's no such thing but.
Speaker 1: That to the best point of personal
inquiry.
Please.
That doesn't exist, Marjorie.
Sorry.
Speaker 4: Second house.
When we strike, it does terminate the time
of the individual who speaking.
Yes.
So the gentlelady is no longer recognized.
The chair now recognizes Mr. Ivie, I believe.
Can I make a point of inquiry?
Mr. Chairman, You can't.
So the the ruling was that because you used
the word liar that was taken down, which I
agree with.
Yes, but.
But accusing a statement of fact is very similar
to the posters that.
Mr..
There's no statement of fact.
No statement.
There's no there's no basis for the statement.
We're not here to debate this.
Okay.
And the ruling was made by the chair that
these previous words were not against the
rules of.
Clause one in clause four of Rule 17.
But to tell someone that they are a liar is
all right.
Speaker 1: So Marjorie Taylor GREENE losing
her right to speak.
These people are really the worst of the worst
of American politics at this point.
And I have to say that for me, one of the
it's sad enough that there are districts in
this country.
With a majority of those who choose to vote,
willing to vote for nonsense like Marjorie
Taylor.
GREENE That's sad in and of itself that someone
like her can even become an elected member
of the House of Representatives.
But the even sadder part.
Is that there are many people in this country,
MAGA types, who will see this and they'll
say she was right, he is a liar and she is
being silenced because the left perceives
her to be such a strong force, a completely
delusional, imaginary made up scenario.
Bonus Clip.
She also goes after friend of the show, Congressman
Eric Swalwell, a Democrat on the committee.
And it's hard to imagine a less, less classy
moment than this.
Speaker 4: It was kept up for months after
Kanye West said that he was in a Claire death
commentary on the Jews.
Mr. Secretary, do you believe that all of
us have a responsibility to elevate our rhetoric
and to denounce antisemitism and anti-police
rhetoric in this country so that Jewish Americans
and police officers can be safer?
Congressman, I do thank you and your back.
The gentleman yields.
And now I recognize the gentle lady from Georgia,
Mr. GREENE.
Speaker 3: That was quite entertaining from
someone that had a sexual relationship with
a Chinese spy and everyone knows it.
Speaker 4: But they moved to take our words
down.
Completely inappropriate.
Yeah.
Stand by just a second while we research the
room.
Speaker 1: And as we know how that turned
out, ultimately, she was banned from speaking
truth.
Truly a disgusting person.
And it really shouldn't come as a shock to
us that the same person who was stalking David
Hogg would behave in this way at a hearing.
And this gets us to what I really want to
introduce to you today the anatomy of the
right wing propaganda cycle.
Let's see if we can figure out what mechanism
is at play underlying a lot of these conspiracy
theories